[Music]
I just pick him up and just keep
slamming him into the floor to the brick
isn't it our other top story shocking
audio of a high school teacher claiming
he'd like to inflict physical harm on a
student the teacher also recorded saying
that he would like to poison the
student's food that student is now suing
the Clark County School District and the
teacher the student's attorney says this
happened
on the Rainbow Boulevard that's where
Joshua peguero Joins us live Joshua
Brian Kirsten the student was enrolled
at Desert Oasis High School in the
special education program but his
attorneys say he started developing
anxiety and depression once he heard the
recordings
I'd love to get him in a room
and just beat them I'll tell I'll pick
him up and just keep throwing it I just
don't like him attorneys say this is the
voice of teacher Courtney Billups
describing what he wants to do to a
student who minutes earlier left the
classroom I just pick him up and just
keep slamming him into the floor
that's the kid that I just don't like
him I don't like what he does I don't
like his energy but I still am the one
wait what these audio recordings were
shared To Us by the law firm now
representing the 14 year old student the
student's name is not listed in the suit
we didn't know the extent to which any
of these threats might be acted on
Taylor Jurgensen of Lago marcino law
says this incident happened last
November at the time the student who is
Black was kicked out of class after
calling another student who took off his
hood the n-word he being Mr Billups told
our client that he was acting like a
slave or he was being a slave or
something along those lines which he
later apparently told our client's mom
that he said that because they were
currently reading a book about a slave
the federal lawsuit alleges four claims
against CCSD including intentional
infliction of emotional distress and
violation of the Civil Rights Act of
1964. it's not something that you should
have to worry about when you send your
kid to school that you know his teacher
and a teacher the special education
department is going to threaten your
kids life
now the 14 year old student is the 14
year old student excuse me is no longer
at Desert Oasis and he's continuing his
studies at another school reporting live
near Rainbow and Cactus Joshua paguero
eight news now